hey guys Ryan right here I'm gonna be
watching the trailer today for southpaw
it's the jake gyllenhaal rachel mcadams
film I love Rachel McAdams she's quite
gorgeous to look at makes my days go by
better Jake Gyllenhaal I can say the
same exact thing he is also incredibly
ripped from photo stills I've seen from
this this guy [ __ ] deserves an Oscar
he's trying really hard he is we should
give it to him in man DiCaprio but Jake
Gyllenhaal first I expected our fight
how much money - a lot how do you fight
I get it let's go fully now just taking
way too many hits before you get off I
can't find like that anymore think about
her oh so predictable with the light
everywhere
I would be thou my wife morning
I really miss all so much you're in
every room oh this Court is aware of the
tragedy your family has suffered mr.
Pope nonetheless you have chosen to
demonstrate dangerous behaviors while
having custody of your body you need
help it would be a year before your
suspension is up which means zero income
legal custody of the child shall remain
with Family Services till the father to
demonstrate the abilities of a
responsible parent
connection no about doing small to a
pretty good Roger I'm looking for a job
maybe place to trade it couldn't hear
the rules here oh [ __ ] is my daughter I
keep you my everything I know you men
here I got no anything she doesn't miss
you today
age so she can get better
I do like the fact that you think that
you can beat me without you I can't
what chance is there that hope could
merely because the stick guess hope
people can make this Joshua please
control your disease
what was it 50 cent credit it's clearly
in the trailer love the way it looks you
know it starts off like okay this is
another boxing film where the wife is
like you know you got to quit fighting
you got to stop and you know he's
conflicted but that moment when rachel
mcadams died like that was a shocker to
me I didn't I didn't see that coming
like I was incredibly heartbreaking last
movie I saw her and she flies through a
car window and it loses her memory I
think in her next movie she's gonna be
throwing herself into a wood chipper I
didn't know this movie was directed by
Anton fuqua like he's a great [ __ ]
director first movie I ever saw his I
think was his first movie the
replacement killers ever since then he's
been great you know he's had movies like
training day Brooklyn's Finest I thought
was underrated
the King Arthur director's cut was
really good actually he seems like he'd
be the perfect director for this cuz
he'd bring the boxing sequences make
those look really intense make those
look really cool but he also knows how
to capture a good human drama and Jake
Gyllenhaal looks like he's knocking it
out the park again
he is just you know ko in his way to the
Oscar round you know so I did made him
more like a boxing thing like I was
getting heartbroken like his wife dies
now he's lost his daughter the daughter
looks like she's doing a really good job
whenever there's a child actor who is
doing great in the movie I mean I know
it's a bold statement to say she's doing
great was just a trailer but just so
most moments alone I was very impressed
you know it's hard to find child actors
who were that good I don't know why I
was a credit in the trailer but 50 cent
looks like he's doing an okay job
I like how 50 Cent's been trying out
roles you know he's not just like I'm
gonna play tough guy he's doing an
actual character in this and sucks it
was a credit in the trailer but I have a
feeling that 57 could be very believable
in this role and of course Forest
Whitaker man Russell Whitaker is the
[ __ ] do you guys see him and Arnold
Schwarzenegger is the last stand
hands-down most impressive thing I've
ever seen him do and something about
Scotland but now the film looks like
it's gonna be badass it's gonna deliver
on epic drama and it's gonna
like some really cool boxing sequences
just from the opening sequence of the
boxing stuff like I was ready cringing
the way it's capturing it doesn't look
like oh this is some cool [ __ ] like it
looks like violent and brutal as like
making me cringe but yeah thanks guys
for telling me that was out that movie
looks really [ __ ] cool if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects and you can follow me on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter
or I tweet loveed things I'm trying not
to talk about my dick try it's really
hard but normally when I bring up the
social networks part I just talk about
my dick Cady Coleman said something
interesting
literally ily he loves me JT Coleman
dude you look like a tough version of
Waldo but you got the beanie the glasses
hey you totally look like Waldo but
really scary version of Waldo Where's
Waldo he's kidnapping someone he's
robbing the bank he's murdering someone
right now he's fleeing the based off
your photos you you've been traveling a
lot so you've been really on the run
because they've really been looking for
Waldo
sorry man I don't know how many people
have told you this Waldo joke before but
now you're getting